foreign
[Music]
thank you
this inevitable one Must Destroy
in order to create
we are no Jedi
[Music]
I started hearing whispers
of thrawn's return as heir to the Empire
what happens when we find thrawn
such as you've never dreamed
[Music]
[Applause]
that's why I'm trying to convince you to
help me prevent another one
you and I both know who could help you
with this
ever
I bet your master found you difficult at
times Anakin never got to finish my
training I walked away from him just
like I walked away from Sabine you never
made things easy for me
master
as a Jedi sometimes you have to make the
decision no one else can
but I'm counting on you to see this
through
nice haircut
sometimes we have to do what's right
regardless of our personal feelings
if we don't stop thrawn everything will
be in vain
[Music]
hour
Anakin spoke highly of you
I'm not here to discuss my past
we have a lot of work to do once the
rebel always a rebel
[Music]